[CHIME RINGING]
JEN HECHT: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jen Hecht and I'm the VP of
People Operations at RStudio.
And I'm thrilled to
be on this stage today
with some folks who are going
to help us talk about building
a career in data science, in
particular around the use of R,
but not exclusively R.
So let me just introduce the
panelists that we have today.
Sitting right next to me,
we have Sydeaka Watson.
She is the founder at
Korelasi Data Insights
and also senior data
scientist at Elicit Insights.
We have David Keyes,
who's a founder
of R for the Rest of Us.
And we also have Gabi de
Queiroz, senior engineering
and data science manager
at IBM, and also founder
at AI Inclusive and R-Ladies.
So, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Very cool.
So I thought we'd get
started by asking each of you
to talk a little bit about
your own experiences sort
of growing your career
in data science.
We've heard, I think,
a few panelists today,
or speakers today,
talk about what
is it to be a data scientist.
I just heard a talk
about salary structures.
And I think it's a topic that's
relevant for a lot of people
in different ways.
I'm interested in hearing
a little bit about how
did each of you experience
milestones in your data science
career?
Or perhaps if you're a
team manager or somebody
working with people that are
learning as data science, what
are the stages of this and how
have you moved through them?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Yeah.
[Pause]
GABI DE QUEIROZ: On.
On.
JEN HECHT: All
right, we have a--
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Hello, hello?
Hello?
JEN HECHT: Can you hear Gabi?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Hello?
OK.
Try this one.
Hello?
No.
OK.
All right.
This one is working.
Cool.
So let me just summarize
kind of like my career path,
because it's interesting and
different from all of us here.
So I was in academia
for about five years
doing research with
air pollution data.
So then I moved to the industry.
So I had this transition
point where I'm like,
I want to try something else.
I want to go to
work for a company.
So then I became
a data scientist.
So I was a statistician
before doing research
and then I became
a data scientist.
Also, I moved to San Francisco.
So statisticians
in San Francisco,
they all became data scientists.
So I was first
working for a startup
and then doing some
kind of like consulting.
And then I moved to
a different startup,
and then became a
lead data scientist,
and then moved again, senior
data scientist, moved again,
became a developer
advocate, and then I
got to a point, an opportunity
to become a manager.
So it's kind of like I don't
know exactly what are the--
you wait two years
and then you did this.
It's kind of like,
it's when I felt ready.
And I think becoming
a manager was
a big jump from all
the other transitions
that I had to go through.
So I felt like, I think I'm
ready to become a manager.
Let's see how it goes.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
OK, great.
DAVID KEYES: [INAUDIBLE].
SYDEAKA WATSON: Is it working?
Nope.
DAVID KEYES: Try [INAUDIBLE].
SYDEAKA WATSON: Hello, hello.
OK, all right.
Hi.
So my path into data
science definitely
has not been
linear, particularly
because my motivations, my
just thoughts about who I was
and what I wanted to become
and the types of things
I wanted to do, they changed.
So for example, when I was
in high school, I thought,
I love math.
The people that I see
around me in high school
are my math teachers.
They love math, and they
became math teachers,
and so I'll be a math teacher.
And then at some
point, I discovered
that there were some other
things beyond education
that you could do
with math, and heard
about being a math
professor, and then found out
about biostatistics
after I became interested
in that type of career.
So I ended up becoming a
biostatistics researcher.
And then as other people have
drank that same data science
Kool-Aid, heard about
all of the cool projects
and the great salary structures
associated with data science,
and decided that that was
something that I wanted to do.
So some of it was just
exposure, where people told me
about other different
types of paths
that I might not have
thought about, and some of it
was just also just restlessness,
change, and interest.
Maybe I was really
happy with my career
as a biostatistician
for the most part.
I didn't have a problem with
my co-workers or the work.
But it was just, I kind of want
to see what else is out there,
and I keep hearing
about this other thing,
so let me just try that.
JEN HECHT: That's great.
DAVID KEYES: I think this one--
can you hear me?
Yeah.
Great.
So first of all, I should say,
I think my current work as well
as my path is pretty
different from the other folks
on this stage.
Unlike them, I work for myself.
My business, as Jen mentioned,
is R for the Rest of Us.
And I primarily focus
on training folks
to use R. And I
particularly focus--
I think of it as kind of like
people who are scared about R,
but want to learn it.
That's kind of my niche.
And how I got into it,
it's very much by accident,
which I know is a story that
resonates with a lot of folks
here.
I'm not very
quantitatively trained.
I have a PhD in anthropology.
My dissertation was
entirely qualitative.
Worked on some mixed methods
projects, kind of butted--
or not butted up against,
but came in contact
with some folks
who were using R.
But never actually
used R in grad school.
And it was actually
only when I started
doing some consulting work
where I was doing what's
called program evaluation
work, looking--
it was kind of applied
social science research,
looking at the impact of
programs run by non-profits,
that type of thing.
And the organization
I was working
for allowed me to use
whatever software I wanted to.
So I taught myself
R. And basically
since then, I
realized that there
was a need for other
people in that industry
as well as others to learn
R. And so I have kind of made
that my thing.
But now I forgot what your
original question was.
So if you want to--
JEN HECHT: Well,
we're free to divert
from my original question.
It's been interesting
to hear all the stories.
I think one theme is
that it's non-linear.
It's not like there's a set
of predefined steps or ladder
or you got to do this before
you move on to the next thing.
You hit on something
that when you
were talking about
having to teach yourself
and not feeling like
you were already
part of a community that was
very quantitative in nature.
And I think that's another
question I had for all of you.
How did you build that
kind of community,
whether you were in industry,
when you were learning,
or you're coming out of
academia, you kind of go
out and find it for yourself?
I know all of you,
in your own ways,
have been involved in
trying to bring other people
through that journey.
But could you talk a
little bit about how
you started to find that for
yourself and how that evolved?
GABI DE QUEIROZ:
Yeah, so I did not
have this community
before back in Brazil.
So when I moved over here
and created R-Ladies,
that was one of the intentions.
It's like, I don't
have a community,
so I'm going to create it.
So that's how it worked for me.
SYDEAKA WATSON: So I
could answer this question
in two different ways, according
to the period of my life
that it relates to.
So in the earlier
periods, of course,
where I'm new to the different
types of mathematical concepts
and different statistical--
I guess I didn't
mention this before.
So my background is in
math and statistics.
So I have a bachelor's in
math, a master's in math,
a master's in statistics,
and a PhD in statistics,
and no student loans.
Yay.
[LAUGHTER]
And so all of those
different types
of educational
experiences put me
into different types
of environments,
where I've got a
particular mix of students,
a particular set of faculty,
who are trying to, together,
help me to learn what I
need to learn from whatever
that perspective is.
And so in some
sense, that community
was curated for me just because
of where I was in school.
But one thing that I've
noticed as a professional
is that you don't always
have the benefit of having
those readily made communities.
Sometimes you just
have to either create
your own community, as
our esteemed panelist
did for R-Ladies.
I'm also an R-Ladies Dallas
chapter organizer as well.
So definitely understand
the value of those.
But sometimes you have to
be just very comfortable
being a community of size
one, and especially in places
where maybe you're the only
one who cares about data,
or you're the only
one who cares about R
or whatever this
new model or tool is
or whatever, where you're
either internally motivated,
and you're just reading
and going online,
looking at blogs or different
types of user groups,
or you're also just going
out, finding meetup groups,
finding different types
of organizations, just
to connect with people who
have similar interests to you.
So I think it helps to develop
yourself internally and also
externally.
DAVID KEYES: And for me, I
think the answer is actually
pretty straightforward.
Online communities, and
particularly Twitter,
have been really fundamental
in terms of my learning of R--
I mean, I can say
without reservation
that I've learned more
about R from Twitter
than any other single source--
but also, finding a community
and building connections
with folks.
I've met so many folks here who
I have known through Twitter.
And I've only used R for three
years, only really kind of got
more involved with this
community in the last couple
years.
The major benefit, if
you're not already aware,
of the Twitter community and
the R community in general
is that it's
extremely welcoming.
And so I know I felt
coming into it, like,
I'm an anthropologist.
I don't have much
quantitative background.
Am I going to be accepted?
And I've never
not felt accepted.
I think because there's such
a diversity of the things
that people do with R and
a number of other reasons,
including, strongly,
the work of R-Ladies,
have made the R community
extremely welcoming.
And so I think putting yourself
out there in that community,
even when you feel
like, you know, who am I
to try and have anything
to say about the world of R
when there's so many people
doing so many amazing things,
it is such a welcoming community
and it is really possible
to find a place in it.
JEN HECHT: That's great.
I'm smiling, because I've had so
many conversations with people
here.
And I think almost
everyone feels that way.
One of the great things about
coming to the conference
is you get to hear amazing
presentations from people
doing cool things.
But I think the
dark side is people
may be wandering around going,
oh, I'm one that doesn't fit.
I have one other
prepared question.
And before I ask it, I want
to just let people know,
you can ask questions for
our panelists on Sli.do
I think this is probably
pretty routine for folks now.
We're in track one and
the code is Hexagon.
So this is a pretty
general question.
But let's make a
broad assumption
that a lot of people
in the room are maybe
in the earlier stages of
their data science career.
If you had, like, a few
minutes to spend with them
and give them advice about how
to grow that in the best way
possible, what advice would
you share with people?
SYDEAKA WATSON: So I can start.
So my background, I mentioned
that I actually went to school
for statistics, and actually
went into a biostats career,
and that was before I even
knew what data science was.
So when I learned what it
was, I realized, especially
as I started looking through
some of the different job
opportunities,
that they would ask
for this long list of skills.
And it was very intimidating.
And we need a person
who knows this
and they know this
and know this.
And it was just, how can
I get that expertise so
that I can just get my foot in
the door into this first role?
And so that would
be one thing that I
would advise you to think about
is to just not be overwhelmed.
Just think about some of
the key principles, I guess,
that I would say are
fundamental to data science.
And I could list it
out as a bulleted list
if you want to write them down.
I would say that there are
three key areas of data science
that you'd want to have
some proficiency in.
One would be, there's obviously
the mathematical component.
So there's where your machine
learning, or maybe even
your deep learning, your
clustering algorithms,
all those kinds of
different algorithms,
even logistic regression,
or ordinary least squares
regression, basic
data analysis--
those types of areas are
very important to get
some proficiency in.
The next would be programming.
So obviously having proficiency
in something like R or Python.
Some type of general use
language, such as one of those,
is ideal.
Not just understanding
specifics of how
to use this package
in that module,
but knowing how to program,
how to be a programmer, how
to actually do the loops
and if-then statements
and actually put together
some piece of code
that accomplishes some task.
So that would be
the second thing.
And the third, I would
say, would be the big data
technologies.
So some of you might be familiar
with SQL or Hadoop, Spark,
Hive, things in that ecosystem.
So having some familiarity
at least on the surface
level in each of
those three areas,
and then developing those
more and more over time
as you get into
whichever specific role
and you learn the specific
needs of that role,
I think that would be a
good place for you to start.
JEN HECHT: Thank you.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Yeah.
I agree with the job
descriptions and all that.
But I think if you
are beginner, even,
like, big data, some companies,
they are not there yet
and they are still on the
Excel spreadsheets, CSV files.
So if big data, it's
like a big thing,
like, you are not
there yet, don't worry,
because I still think there
are some several companies that
are still doing small data,
working with small data.
But yeah, the job description
is, like, don't even
bother to learn all
the technologies,
because there is no way--
like, I have no idea how
people know all that.
That is the Unicorn, right?
So the companies,
they want this Unicorn,
and you as a data scientist, you
don't have to know everything,
because if they are
looking for the Unicorn
and you are the Unicorn,
you're probably not going
to work for that company.
You are going to be working for
a different company, either.
So if you are trying to
get into the data science,
I would say apply for jobs.
You are going to feel
that are you not ready
and that's a feeling that you
are going to have forever.
You are never ready.
So just apply,
apply, apply, apply,
and try to get a sense of how
the interview processes are,
because they vary so much.
Like, some companies are
going to be asking questions
around probability.
Other companies are going to
ask you questions more general,
like, just to get
your thinking, how
you think about the problems.
So I just would say, if you are
looking for a job, just apply.
Don't wait, because you
will never be ready.
DAVID KEYES: So my answer
will be very much tailored
to my work, which is
basically as a consultant.
I think I would offer
two pieces of advice.
One is to try and
find a niche if you
are thinking about trying
to do some consulting.
One of the major advantages of
R is it's multifaceted, right?
You can do so many
different things with R.
And as an R user, you know
that and you get very excited.
I think I've found, as a
consultant working with folks,
it can be overwhelming
to come in--
because I do training and then
I also sometimes actually will
do some work for folks.
I'll get really excited and I'll
say, well, we can do this in R
and that in R and this
in these 10 other things,
and that can be
overwhelming for folks.
And so I think really
kind of like trying
to focus on what you can
particularly offer to a client
if you are thinking about
doing some consulting.
So for example, I focus,
when I'm not training,
I mostly do data visualization,
because that's an area
that I'm pretty strong in.
So having that niche,
I think, is important.
The-- well, I totally blanked
on what my other thing was.
I will come back to
it if I remember.
JEN HECHT: OK.
Cool.
I'll just add that in my
experience working in HR,
most job descriptions
are terrible.
[LAUGHS] Honestly.
Like, especially
in data science,
half the things
on there, there's
no human that could
possibly do it.
So you shouldn't let
that get in your head.
I'll just add that.
OK, so with your
permission, panel,
I'm going to go to some
questions from our folks
out here.
The first one has 30 people
asking this question.
I'm trying to decide whether
to maintain a technical role
or try to shift into
management and decision-making.
Any tips on what to do
if I want to do both?
SYDEAKA WATSON: Yeah.
That's a struggle
that I go through.
And before becoming
a manager was--
the thing that I was
most afraid of is,
like, am I going to be in
this sea of bureaucracy
and then I'll lose all my
technical skills that I worked
so hard for several years?
I was not sure.
So I talked to a few folks
in the company, especially
the company that I work for,
asking them, how was your path?
And then how do you
feel about keeping up
with the technical
piece as well?
So in large corporations,
in particular,
you don't have to go
one way or the other.
You can kind of
go in the middle.
And you can also, like,
always go back and forth.
So you can become a manager and
go for the management track,
but you can also come back
to the technical track
for a few years, and
then come back again
to the management track.
So that's the beauty
of some companies
where you can go back and
forth, so you keep developing.
The other thing is try
to get some time for you.
Like, let's say on Fridays, I
try to schedule no meetings.
And then I go to our corner
in the room in the office,
and then I put my headphone
on, and then I just
do some coding or code review.
So that's my strategy
to keep me happy,
because there is a piece of
me that I miss if I'm not
doing technical work.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
Makes sense.
SYDEAKA WATSON: I've had
that same fear, actually.
So I was actually kind
of interested to hear
what other people had
to say about this,
because I've been invited
to go into management
and into director-level
roles, but I like
having my hands on the data.
I like having my
finger on the pulse
of all the different types
of cool tools and strategies
that are out there.
And so I don't
want to lose that.
So part of me is nervous.
So I haven't made that jump.
But I would say that
was something that--
I really like those tips--
doing things that help you to
continue to work those muscles.
So I know some
people who actively
had to go on
HackerRank every day
and do some coding
exercises in the morning
or actually participate
in code reviews and so on.
So I would imagine that would
be a really good strategy.
Yeah.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Just one
thing that I was thinking now,
so if there is anything
that I need to measure--
let's say I need to measure
something on my team
and then I'm like, yes,
I have some time for me
to create our shiny where I'm
going to measure something.
So I try to translate
tasks that I
need to do in a coding exercise,
so I keep up with my coding.
Yeah.
We can talk.
Like, it's a big jump.
It's a big jump for sure.
It's so different.
But also, you are
developing other pieces
of your brain, your
skills, that is
going to help you also in the
future as a coder, programmer.
So another example
that I was thinking
is one day I had
to write something.
And then it came.
Like, things were
coming through my mind.
And I'm like, OK, I didn't
forget those things.
And then I became
a better searcher,
or I don't know how to say that.
But I can now
search even better,
because there is some
piece of my brain
that got developed
a little bit better,
so I know exactly how to look
for answers, where before I
would struggle much more.
So I don't know.
Yeah, it's something
interesting, I think.
And if you have
the ability to, you
know, I want to
become a manager,
I'm going to give,
like, a time--
I'm going to timebox
this for two years.
I'm going to try it
out for two years.
It's like, if I don't
like it, can I go back?
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
That's great.
And David, from what
you were saying before,
you have your hands in doing
direct work as a consultant
and data visualization,
and you're teaching.
So you've been able to
combine those a bit as well.
DAVID KEYES: And if you work for
yourself, you get to do both.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
DAVID KEYES: Better or worse.
JEN HECHT: Yeah, that's great.
OK, another very
popular question up here
is, can you talk about
salary negotiations?
Any tips?
SYDEAKA WATSON: OK, I'll start.
[LAUGHS] All right, so I'll
start with a story, something
that actually happened.
So I was a contractor
working at a company,
along with a friend, a male
colleague, who was also
a contractor.
And he ended up deciding
to go into another company.
And as they were
negotiating his salary,
they asked him, how much
are you currently making,
which, of course, is the trap,
because the next company wants
to just kind of keep you
around where you are and maybe
give you a little bit more.
And that is the
trap question that
keeps the income inequality for
men versus women so prevalent.
But he got that question.
And so he gave a very
creatively high answer, which
I don't necessarily recommend.
But I think he said
something like, I'm currently
making $200,000.
And he wasn't making $200,000.
He said, I'm currently
making $200,000.
And so the response was, oh,
there's no way in the world
I can pay you $200,000.
The best I could do is 175.
Is that OK?
Which, to me, I would
have never even dreamed
of giving some sort of
number that high, because I
think in a lot of
times, we don't
value ourselves to be that.
I'm not worth $175,000.
You might be saying
that to yourself.
Well, maybe I'll give
them a lower number,
or I don't want them to think
that I'm just too greedy,
or something like that.
So I think what helps in
those types of situations
would be to, first of all,
understand the market,
understand what a
reasonable amount of money
would be for that particular
role for your area,
like, a geographic area,
and also for your specialty
and for your years
of experience.
And the worst that they
could do is say no, right?
I mean, you give them a
reasonable number that
is in line with a salary
that you can justify,
the worst they could say is,
no, it's a little bit lower.
But I definitely just
encourage you to, like I said,
just think a little bit more
outside of the box and value
yourselves, I guess, maybe
higher than potential--
because they obviously have
a vested interest in keeping
your salary as low as possible.
They just want you in the door
in the cheapest way possible.
So yeah, I highly encourage
you to actually negotiate
your salary.
JEN HECHT: You raise a great
point about the prior salary,
because that's totally illegal.
I know it is in
Massachusetts now to ask
that question in an interview.
I don't know how many other
states have gone there.
But that's the reason why
is that it automatically
kind of drags people
down, especially those who
are unwilling to get
creative in their ask.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: One thing
that I kind of learned to do
is to have a network
of people that I
have some kind of like open
space or open conversation,
where I can ask the questions.
I can say, I'm
looking for a job.
I have this amount of
years of experience.
And how much do you
think I should ask for?
And they say, oh,
I'm a senior person.
I know that my company
is paying around this.
So I kind of like did a survey
with my friends or the people
that I know and asked them, what
is the average or the interval
that you think I
should be asking for?
The other good thing
and tip is if you
have any friend that is manager
or hiring manager, ask them,
because they know a lot about
the salaries in the industry.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
And the other thing I
would say about that,
too, is-- and you want to
be careful with this advice,
because if you're working in
a very conservative industry,
this might be harder to do.
But you should be able to
talk with your colleagues
in your current job
about what you're making.
And that can be
very scary, but it's
a good way to get information.
And I think the workplace
is changing a lot.
One of the positive things is,
I think, more transparency.
But if you have
people that you work
with in your same
discipline that you trust,
I'd encourage you to do that
even where you are right now.
And again, I've worked
in a range of places.
I think most places are kind
of stopping this practice.
It used to be like, oh,
you cannot discuss salary,
which I think also keeps a lot
of people in the dark about
what the real ranges are.
OK, I'm going to go
to the next question.
How do you decide which
technical skills are
worth the time investment to
really learn versus having
a passing acquaintance with?
SYDEAKA WATSON: I think it would
depend on your specific role
and whether or not
that is something
that is needed for your
job or for your growth.
So I think about, for example,
going back to that list of--
that massively long list of
different types of machine
learning tools and
software and models
and all these different
kinds of things.
In your particular job, maybe
you only need clustering.
Like, they need somebody
who's an expert at clustering
and they need somebody
who understands
all the different ins and
outs of a very small number
of models.
In that sense, maybe
it's worth the effort
of really digging in
and understanding those.
But the other side
of that, obviously,
is that what that
does is that keeps you
in the expert role for where you
are now or maybe with the team
that you're currently in.
So another view of that will be
to say, where do I want to go,
or what is the
type of job that I
want to have or
the type of career
that I want to have
for myself eventually?
When I answer that
question for myself,
I want to be not just the best
data scientist at my company,
I want to be the best
data scientist possible,
so that any company can look at
me and all the different types
of experiences that
I've had and say,
wow, she really
understands a lot
of different kinds of
tools, she understands
that AI, for example, that's
the buzzword of the day,
and a lot of companies
are interested in that,
and so she's the person
that I would want to call,
because she has that
type of expertise.
So I would definitely
challenge you
to think about your
career and the path
that you want to go on, and
figure out whether or not
some of these different types
of tools will be useful.
And some of that requires
reading in the literature,
but also looking at
different use cases
to see how other people
are using it and the value
that they're able to get from
some of these different types
of tools or models.
JEN HECHT: This question
actually came up
in a session I was in earlier.
What is the difference between
a data analyst and data
scientist?
In your experience,
is there a difference?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: So
in some companies,
there is no distinction.
It's more like a title.
But from my experience,
data analyst
is doing more querying
the data, getting the data
from a database,
let's say using SQL,
creating reports, where data
scientists go one step further,
where they also do
the data cleaning,
munging, and querying the
data, but also is involved
on the modeling itself.
So that's my experience.
But I think it's kind
of like a gray area.
Like, some companies,
they call data analyst
what I consider
being data scientist.
And they have different names,
yeah, even more names than data
analyst and data scientist.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
SYDEAKA WATSON: These
are all squishy terms.
So I guess maybe just
thinking about some
of the different
roles I've had, people
who've had the data
scientist role, they tend
to have a little
bit more training,
maybe a little bit
more education,
like, formal training in maybe
like a math or statistics
or physics or
something like that.
They tend to, again.
Again, there's no
hard, fast rule
for any of these
different types of things.
And they tend to have a
little bit more expertise
in some of the more advanced
types of modeling scenarios,
whereas maybe a
data analyst would
be very proficient
in some of the data
engineering tasks, or pulling
different types of SQL queries,
and maybe creating some
dashboards or some reports.
But the deeper insights
of trying to understand,
maybe starting with
the question, of why
are we losing so much money
in this particular area
of our company and this kind
of product in our company?
When I think of
a data scientist,
I think of a scientist,
where you actually have
to start from the beginning.
Nobody's handing you a CSV
or telling you specifically
which types of data to look
at or what types of models
to use and so on.
You're starting from
scratch, and you're
able to go through that
entire scientific process
and figure out where
your hypotheses are,
testing those, maybe validating
those, maybe circling
back and going back
to the beginning.
And so that entire process,
I would think of that
as that the person that has that
type of holistic set of skills
is a data scientist as well.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: And one last
thing is data scientists,
they usually make
much more money--
SYDEAKA WATSON: Yes.
GABI DE QUEIROZ:
--than data analysts.
SYDEAKA WATSON: There is that.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: So
if you are in doubt
if you should write
in your resume
that you are data analyst
or data scientist,
go for data scientist.
SYDEAKA WATSON: That's right.
JEN HECHT: Yeah.
Well, it gets complicated,
because in some companies,
there's the official job
title that's owned by HR,
and then they'll let people
make up business titles that
say anything you want.
So I've seen cases of somebody
gets hired as a business
intelligence analyst, and
three weeks later, they're
a data scientist.
You're like, wow, that was fast.
OK.
So a good question
here about how
do you handle being in a job
with little or no mentorship
opportunities?
SYDEAKA WATSON: I kind of
touched on this earlier.
I've definitely been that--
how can I say it?
I've been that person that
has the set of skills,
that one particular set
of skills that nobody else
in the company has.
So they literally cannot
speak to me about it.
And not to say
that I'm inherently
smarter than them necessarily.
Everybody has their
own specialty.
But maybe I'm the
only one that has
studied this particular area.
And so I can't talk to them
about those kinds of topics.
And so what I have to do
is create my own network.
Just in the course of
being a person who's
interesting in developing my
network in Dallas, for example,
I go to different events.
I go to different talks
and just talk to people
and find out what they're
interested in, so then when
I come across some
kind of problem
and I just like, oh, I
don't know what to do
or where should I go next
with this, oh, wait a minute,
David knows this.
He sounds like
the kind of person
that would have that
kind of expertise.
Maybe I can tap him.
So that's one area
when you think
about technical mentorship.
But the other path would be
just growth for your career.
So just figuring out, I want
to be a director someday
or I want to be a
technical leader someday,
how can I do that?
And so some of that
is just finding
people who have gone
through that path
that you're trying
to go through.
And that could be
within your own company.
That could be for people who
work in similar types of roles
as you're trying to
get into, maybe who've
been in different companies.
So try to just be creative about
finding people that can inspire
you in the ways that you need.
JEN HECHT: That's great.
David, I'm going to
direct this one to you.
Can you recommend any
good Twitter accounts
to follow to learn
more about data?
And already mentioned you
highly leverage Twitter.
What would you recommend?
DAVID KEYES: Well, if you're not
already following Mara Averick,
that's probably the best
place to start, definitely
where I think I've learned
more than anything.
Jeez.
There's so many people.
I'm trying to think of
some other ones that
have been particularly
informative for me.
I would say, this isn't
an account, but the--
and particularly when
you're developing
in data visualization
especially,
the #TidyTuesday hashtag
has been really helpful
for me to see folks who
are doing some really
interesting data visualization.
That's been a helpful one.
Yeah, I think I'd
probably start there.
JEN HECHT: Great.
Anyone else have any thoughts?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: What
about the #rstats hashtag?
DAVID KEYES: Yeah.
Sorry.
I assumed that was--
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
But yes, #rstats hashtag
if you're not already
following that as well.
The other thing, actually,
looking over at you
for a second, Gabi, makes
me think that I really
like the R-Ladies, @WeAreRLadies
rotating curator, because it's
really fun to see
kind of each week.
It's a different person
who curates the account.
And it's really fun just
to see the different types
of work that people are doing
and the different packages they
use.
So I really like
that account as well.
JEN HECHT: Great.
So this question is more
about R versus other things.
So I'm fundamentally a
generalist in my overall skills
and my R skills,
breadth not depth.
Is that a viable way to build
a career or is specializing
essential?
SYDEAKA WATSON: For sure.
JEN HECHT: It's
valid, you're saying?
Yeah.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: No,
like, this person
is saying that all
they know, it's R?
JEN HECHT: They're
saying they're
a generalist in their overall
skills and their R skills.
And they're wondering, is that
a viable way to build a career
or should they be specializing
within that, either in data
science or in R, I guess?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Well,
I think, again, there
is a broad of, like, jobs.
So you can be a generalist or
you can be a very specific.
It all depends.
I think there is--
maybe you have a
better opinion than I.
But I think there is
space for everybody
for being a generalist and to
be a very, like, domain expert.
SYDEAKA WATSON: Right.
And I think I touched on this
a little bit in the beginning
when I was thinking about
the different types of ways
to classify the different types
of skills that are required
as part of a data scientist.
And so I was saying,
if I wanted to just
be a person that a general
data science company would find
attractive, then I
would have proficiency
in machine learning,
programming, and big data
technologies.
And as our esteemed
panelist said earlier,
some of those companies might
not necessarily care about some
of those, right?
So they might not care
about the big data part.
Maybe they only care
about the other two.
But when I think about it,
again, unless you've already
decided specifically, I know
that this job in particular
is what I want, and I
know the specific set
of skills that are
required for that job,
and I'm just going
to keep on honing
those skills, unless you're
doing that, I would challenge
you to branch out
a little bit more,
learn about other
types of things.
But obviously, you don't
want to get to the point
where you're just picking
up every single kind of tool
or every type of
model or expertise.
At some point, you're going
to have to specialize,
because the people who
have very specific domain
experience, like baseball,
like telecommunications,
and so on, they really
understand the data.
So they can go
beyond just saying,
I understand that
this column seems
to be related to this column.
They really understand
all the different ways
that extra knowledge
can inform how well you
can get some insights from
some of those different types
of projects.
So I would encourage you
for your specific area,
once you've actually
determined that there's
a specific area that is of
interest to you, that you
learn, you take the time to
develop that domain experience.
And the good thing about it
is that if you get into it
and you realize, eh, I kind
of thought I would like this,
but I don't like it so much,
then you can get experience
in something else.
So yeah, just try
different things.
But I definitely
would encourage you
to have some type of
specialization in some areas.
JEN HECHT: Great.
We have a couple of questions
sort of in this topic area
about how you have
dealt with being
perhaps the only or first
woman or person of color
in your organization or team.
Do you have any
advice for people
who might be, in
addition to trying
to get into data
science, also dealing
with issues in that area?
SYDEAKA WATSON: So I have been
in that scenario from the woman
and also the person
of color scenario
in so many of the roles
that I've been in--
actually, I want to say
every role that I've been in.
And yeah.
And so one of the things
that happens, commonly,
is that as the one
person, you feel like you
have to be the representative.
If I mess up, then now
all black people mess up,
right, you know, that's just how
we are, or all women mess up,
right?
So some things you just kind
of have to forgive yourself
and realize that you're human
just like everybody else.
You make mistakes just
like everybody else.
And just take those as growing
opportunities to get better.
But some of the challenges
are external, some of them
are internal.
So I definitely would just
encourage you to realize, yeah,
I'm a good person, too.
I'm very smart.
And I have a lot of great
ideas and good things to offer.
And so just kind of
keep that in mind
as you're growing your career.
GABI DE QUEIROZ: Yeah, also,
don't feel like you have to be
the one responsible-- like,
let's say there is no diversity
efforts and then you are going
to be the one doing the whole
work, because--
so, like, try to get other
people to help you as well,
to have allies.
And also, the outside network is
very important in those times,
so you don't feel lonely, so
we have this support around you
that keeps you going.
JEN HECHT: Great.
So all of you had
such different paths.
But we have a
question here about,
for a young data scientist
trying to get their first job,
should they be looking at
large companies or startups?
Do you have any specific
advice about what context might
be the best place to start?
GABI DE QUEIROZ: So I
always worked for startups
until moving to IBM
almost two years ago.
So I went from a company
where we were 20 people
to, like, 300,000.
It's a big jump.
I don't know what is better.
I think if you are a
beginner, the best company
is the company
where, again, you are
going to have support
mentorship, because it's
so hard to break
into this career
without having
someone mentoring you.
So if there is a startup,
that you have a good network
and support, yeah, go for it.
But if you have opportunity
to work for a big company,
you probably have
more mentorship.
But also, like,
you are going to be
more specialized
in a startup, where
you have to do everything
from getting the data,
cleaning the data, data
engineering, modeling,
and putting protection,
for example.
DAVID KEYES: Can I
also just give a pitch
for the idea of potentially
considering consulting,
because I think it's a
really good way that you
can gain experience.
And even if your
ultimate goal is
to become, say,
a data scientist,
I think there are a
lot of opportunities
to use the types of skills
that you have as an R user
outside of that title
in ways that can really
be impactful for
the organizations
that you work for.
I mean, just as a
minor example, one
of the clients that I was
training recently was working,
doing an evaluation of
an after-school program.
And they were working
at 100 different schools
and they had to produce
literally 100 reports.
I taught them about
parameterized reporting
and it just completely blew
their mind, the idea that they
could automate that and not
have to manually produce
100 reports.
They're not a data science firm.
That's not how they
identify themselves.
But those types of skills
can be really useful
and serve a wide variety
of organizations.
And you can do that
sometimes through consulting.
JEN HECHT: I actually have a
follow-up question directed
to you, David, on that
point, which is, how did you
get started consulting?
How did you start
out finding clients?
And how has that
changed over time?
DAVID KEYES: So I
started out consulting--
the honest answer is
because I had twins
three and 1/2 years ago and
I wanted more flexibility
than in the job that
I had at the time.
I started out finding clients--
I've mostly done
online marketing.
I offer online courses as well
as trainings for organizations.
And I've tried to
basically become
a resource for other folks.
So I write a lot of blog
posts really pitched
at newcomers learning
about packages to make
effective tables or
that type of thing.
And that's really been my
most effective strategy
to reach out to clients.
JEN HECHT: That's great.
So I think we're right at time.
So I'd love to give a round
of applause to the panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[CHIME RINGING]